hey guys dr. Burke here in this video
we're going to talk about neuroma pain
now what is a neuroma
it's basically fibrous tissue that's
scar tissue that wraps around a nerve at
the bottom of your foot making it very
difficult to walk and it's usually
between to what's called metatarsals
which are the bones in your foot which I
will show you in just a moment okay so
it's a scar tissue that wraps around the
nerve that makes it very painful to move
your foot or walk on it now what causes
neuroma neuromas or Morton neuromas they
don't know but I believe it comes from
an old injury which is going to relate
to how I'm going to show you how to get
rid of the pain but I believe this
technique I'm going to show you is the
only way you're going to knock out pain
without drugs and surgery you want to
see I'll show you
okay guys this is how you do it number
one let's pretend she has pain right
here and these are the metatarsals these
extensions of these toes right through
here okay so usually going to have a
neuroma like right about here or here
maybe right here now what you're going
to do you're going to press on the
opposite foot that mirrors the image of
where that neuroma is so if it's between
this little pinky one to mark now
between this little toe and this tail
right here you'll press between this
little toe in this toe on the mirror
image opposite side now when I press on
the opposite side what you're going to
notice it's going to hurt like hell okay
so go light and you can do this on
yourself if you like pain now just going
you could do this on yourself or get
someone else to do it but the key is
pressing on the opposite foot no one
does this what they're going to do is
are going to work on where the injury
was do therapy it's going to make it
worse especially if you got surgery for
it it's like a reit Ramah it's like
hitting your thumb over and over again
so we're going to press on the up to
side and you're going to just massage it
and you're going to find oh my gosh
that's still painful in fact this side
will be more painful than this side when
you press on it but not normally now go
light the first time
okay so you're actually sending a signal
up to the brain to turn these pain
signals off that's what you're doing so
you're working on the nerve signals
because it's not a feedback loop this
foot is connected to this foot through
the spinal column okay now here's a
little trick what you want to do the way
that you know you found the exact spot
is to find the point of the most pain
okay so you might want to go up a little
bit down to the left to the right and
you're going to hit like the epicenter
of the pain and then what you're going
to do is you're going to just stay on
that point and work that and then what
you can do you can you know ask yourself
how is this feeling now and I like to
rate it can being really bad zero being
no pain and I keep you know kind of
rating the pain it's going to come down
down down down down till it's at zero
it's gone but what happens is this pain
original pain might shift it might move
over to the left right up or down so
what you do is you just move your finger
to the opposite or mirroring mirroring
that pain and keep working that out
until all the pain is gone okay now
what's going to happen you're going to
decide it's going to feel really really
good okay you're going to walk on it and
then the next day you're going to do it
again and this might even be a little
sore so you want to go light at first
until finally over like a week or two
when it's like really minimal okay this
doesn't necessarily correct the neuroma
it gets rid of the pain from the Roma
it's a great technique in fact it's the
only technique that I know that'll knock
the pain out better than any drug or
surgery without the side effects okay so
go ahead and attempt this at your own
risk and put your comments below